tiens voilà vigueur au stade de france
le wb
le dvd du spectacle plus méconnus
maintien de classes moyennes soit on
s'allie à une fête de top model il est
bien là attendez un certifié ou quoi là
non c'est une vraie photo numérique chez
selligent à ses dents à qui convient est
en baisse à retoucher son jeu qui aime
bien je coûte la matinée les femmes sont
beaucoup plus agressif c'est vrai
vraiment qu'est ce que vous en voyez
comme c'est laisser rentrer il brave
c'est très impressionnant quand même ça
c'est là moi j'y croyais pas je te vois
franchement quand tu que tu m'en a parlé
52000 invite bien qu'ayant baissé mais
quand tu es roncq les lattes avait le
trac a envie de te tuer qua non oui
surtout il ya eu une la qui s'est
déclenchée qui a duré 13 minutes selon
18 oui oui c'est bien
chaque stade hardcore de all away et et
puis mon petit franck vestiaire est venu
me voir au bout d'une dizaine de minutes
il m'a dit je crois que les gens
attendaient j'ai dit ouais je crois qui
est qui qui m'attend des jeux
j'entendais ça et j'étais je vais le
coeur à l'envers j'ai fait une prière à
dieu et j'ai demandé à dieu que ça avec
vous que ce stade ne gonfle pas mon ego
nous vraiment c'était très important que
ce soit pas vraiment que de la branlette
10 2 fois et il a accédé à ma prière
diack en fait j'ai pendant un an j'ai
hurlé à la terre entière que j'allais
faire un truc exceptionnel et le
lendemain rien donc c'était quand même
fabuleux lendemain qu'avaient les dettes
oui parce que ce jeu marek la répète 5
millions d'euros déjà qu'ils pourraient
donc aujourd'hui qui est quand même
d'ordes 2,3 millions d'euros à peu près
non ouais
[ __ ] t'es vachement bien renseignés
ouais fait ça pour que ce soit une
grande fête le 1er prix de place était à
15 euros alors que la visite du stade
vide est de 10 euros et je les fais pour
que ça fonctionne et g10 budget illimité
on dit à la lumière et eau sont prêts
plus personne ne dit ça c'est à dire tu
dis plus jamais dans un troquet tournée
générale ça n'existe plus et moi j'ai
dit budget illimité dont ils ont
dépassés ils ont crevé tous les plafonds
et en fait cette fête a eu lieu il faut
que tu inventes combien des dvd pour
rentrer dans ses sauts comme ça on va
t'aider je préfère se le dise
franchement à partir de 358 cette
opération blanche mais astra blanche
sauf que pour l'éternité
il ya aurait fait ça voilà donc chez
vous si vous avez envie d'un dvd pour
les fêtes de noël contre on peut le dire
ouais tu recherches 350 mille personnes
je sais déjà une chose je sais déjà une
chose parce que moi j étais ce jour là
je sais qu'il ya 52 mille personnes qui
vont acheter ce truc là ouais parce que
il n'avait qu'un seul point de vue est
que ce truc est monté l'arrière 17 la
10ième à 50 milles devant j ai géré les
trois cent mille noms mais je sais
qu'avec le 5 avec le 5 + 1 tu vois là
aux lattes as 2 5 points
oui bien sûr adacore jusque c'est nadine
les cinq plus un nom c'est le home
cinéma
c'est comme le dernier fils de jean
michel jarre c'est à dire que ben oui
c'est vrai c'est à dire que vous
entendez comme le home cinéma
il ya du sang tout autour d'un plan
danton tunisien la ola qui passent de
droite à gauche passe dessus elles
passent de droite à gauche chez toi donc
tu te fais rouler dessus par là par la
ola tués dans la place idéale du stade
voilà avec le meilleur point de vue des
dix sept caméras à la java
les gars
le spectacle événement jean marie bigard
au stade de france
awd vient encore 300 milles avant de
mesdames messieurs effet chez vous
vous apprenez à dire non si l'on prend
dès lors très difficile on peut pas
faire ça un oui non peut pas bon alors